is your Royal Highnesses laureates
ladies and gentlemen they are in store
era at focus on tiara Nobel Prize
targeting facility no abravit synagogue
show - Shoshanna gotta go show Kyle
dekiru koto wa tahun Kuwaitis it is a
great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in physics professor
Shuji Nakamura
Your Majesty Royal Highnesses
ladies and gentlemen courage and friends
on behalf of my co-recipients professor
ISM akasaki and professor
hiroshi amano I'd like to thank the
members of Nobel Prize selection
committee and members of the Swedish
royal academy of science for honouring
our invention of the efficient blue
light-emitting diode which has enabled
bright and energy-saving white light
sources Alfred Nobel wanted his prize to
be awarded based on invention or
discovery in physics that during the
preceding year sir have comfort greatest
benefit on mankind
therefore we are deeply honored that the
dream of LED lighting has now become a
reality and is greatly benefiting
mankind nowadays you can buy
energy-efficient LED light bulbs at the
supermarket and help reduce energy use
LED lighting is 10 times more efficient
than conventional in Kunduz lamp so we
can drastically reduce energy
consumption
I believe that LED lighting can also
reduce global warming - in addition by
combining LED with solar cell we can
give sustainable writing to the 1.5
billion people without electricity that
cost-effective quick and safe to read
writing the world my laurels at the UCSB
physics nobel laureate in 2000 professor
Herbert kroemer said about right LED
lighting we are not just talking about
doing things better
but about doing since we never could
before you have forever change the world
now every passenger experience LED
lighting if I can t really tree story of
encouragement when we began work on the
blue LEDs in the 1980s we were told
again and again that what we were trying
to do was impossible still it was weird
working hard for many hours and years to
develop this new technology
after the breakthroughs in making the
bright blue LEDs by professors akazake
Amano and myself an explosion of
research activity occurred southern of
researchers joined the field and applied
led to many field such as mobile phone
screens LED television and LED lighting
alone is professor ism akazake and
professor Yoshi Amano I'll Drive to some
of the Swedish royal academy again for
audit this price to our invention of
blue LED and an energy-efficient LED
light I will drive also life to solve
all of my curries at Nietzsche and UCSB
and my family for letting me work so
hard today I hope that everyone can now
is efficient LED lighting to save energy
tact thank you
you